alright I'm excited I haven't got to
talk about a cult classic 80s movie in a
while
Project X stars Matthew Broderick what's
that hmm this isn't the movie with the
chimps Project X has had a lot of hype
it seems like every time they release a
found footage style movie it just gets
hyped insanely now Chronicle was very
good I didn't see the devil inside a
skip ten point a lot of people said that
one was not good but it seemed like
Chronicle kind of revitalized as John
we're gonna give it a chance this movie
is a found footage style film but it's
showing basically what is considered
like the greatest high school party ever
basically these three young teenagers in
high school decide you know what we're
not very popular let's try to throw like
the biggest party ever to hopefully get
some chicks tonight we've definitely
never seen a movie like that before have
we there's been a lot of hype behind
this movie and I tried an experiment I
purposefully did not watch one trailer
for this movie a lot of people are
saying that all the funniest parts and
the best parts are in the trailer so I'm
glad I missed it we just gave you like a
really quick example of what this movie
is like in like 10 seconds so you can
decide whether or not you want to see it
[Applause]
what's this a random pill I don't care
if you can deal with that for 90 minutes
you'll probably enjoy this movie I
wasn't hype for this movie at all I went
in with absolutely no expectations as
just a completely objective viewer I had
the blinders on to any of the hype I
hadn't seen any trailers and you know
what this movie ain't that great a lot
of people saw the trailer and they were
like oh this could be really fun this
could be a cool college high school
party movie basically half the movie is
like that it's just kind of people like
wing into the camera going yeah the best
part yeah and this movie really has the
biggest problem that I have with found
footage films you don't buy that it's a
found footage movie there are so many
moments and you're like who in the world
is filming this right now in fact
there's a scene towards the end of the
movie where the party is over and the
guy who is filming the party is long
gone he's left and now the kid is
talking to somebody else and I'm like
who is filming this right now who in the
world is filming this event the party's
over there's nobody in there long who's
filming this also the filmmakers added
music to the movie to overlay over the
scenes and it wasn't like just the music
they were listening to while they were
dancing
they had montages and stuff in it and so
it lost the whole feel of a found
footage film and became an actual movie
documentary-style so the movie like kind
of loses its feel a lot for me anyway
this movie was incredibly annoying at
times because I would be kind of the
neighbor who's like shut up I'm trying
to sleep I'm not the kind of guy who
like goes out and gets insanely wasted I
don't do drugs I can't relate to these
kids who went like a giant pill bottle
explodes on the ground
everyone just scrambles to pick up the
pills to pop them they're all gonna stop
their hearts and I'm gonna sound like
I'm 80 years old but this movie honestly
sets like the worst example for kids it
really does it says that it's okay to do
ecstasy and apparently if you don't like
to drink alcohol you're gay it's okay to
burn your house down it's okay to have
the SWAT team come to your house and in
the end your parents are just gonna not
really care and it's all fine and you're
popular at school now and you got the
girl but it's okay to do all those other
things and these people didn't but I
hate when movies make it look like it's
okay to do the kind of things that kids
end up dead or on side of the road like
hit by a car some of the strong points
of the movie are that it's not boring
it's basically 80 minutes of a party
it's not a boring film there are a few
funny parts but it really is just trying
to be super bad with a found footage
style it honestly is exactly like super
bad almost a hundred percent like super
bad except without the interesting
characters without the fun dialogue and
it has has none of the heart of super
bad either I will say that if you are
the person who wants to go see this
movie who sees the trailer thinks yeah
man that'd be awesome they'd be like the
best movie ever then you'll probably
love this movie you're probably gonna
leave the theater and be really happy
about it and it's not gonna know you
you're gonna think that's cool I'm gonna
go out tonight and do the exact same
thing however this just isn't my kind of
movie and I'm gonna give Project X of
c-minus so I'd like to know do you have
like a favorite high school movie I
think mine's 10 Things I Hate About You
I think that's a really fun clever movie
and I just that movie's hilarious I love
that movie do you have a favorite one
until next time guys if you liked this
review you can subscribe to my channel
and get stuck mine eyes
[Music]